hey guys Pete here since the finale of
Watchmen is fast approaching I'm gonna
do a bonus video today about the top
questions I want answers to in the final
episode this list is things that I think
we can expect to get answers to or at
least get an idea of what they had in
mind with it it won't contain all the
small little things but I will mention a
lot of those as I go through the rest of
the video overall I think they've done a
pretty good job of setting up mysteries
deliberately leaving clues and then
paying things off in a way that's pretty
satisfying so these are the top things I
think that will get answers to because
we're supposed to want answers to them
and you guys can add to this in the
comments number 1 what does the
millenium clock do most of the big
mysteries that I'm interested in all
revolve around lady true the clock has
been a big centerpiece in Tulsa she's
been building it for over a year the
only thing we know about it is it's
nearly indestructible and that beyond
says that it tells time there have been
a lot of theories across the board about
what this thing does and at this point I
just want to know what it's for in my
trailer breakdown this week I talked
about some things that we saw there and
I honestly don't know what they mean we
think this thing is going to be a major
part of what her plan is so that leads
us into the next one number two what is
Lady trues actual goal what is she
trying to do she says she's trying to
save humanity she's led on to Angela
that she knows that the 7th cavalry is
trying to capture dr. Manhattan and that
they want to destroy him we know that
she has been working with Will Reeves
they have something planned that's gonna
happen soon when the clock goes live is
what we expect this also seems to be
coinciding with the 7th cavalry taking
dr. Manhattan prisoner and it probably
has something to do with the Millennium
clock that we were just talking about a
lot of the ideas have been that she
wants revenge against the United States
and possibly even dr. Manhattan for the
Vietnam War or that she is actually
trying to change the world and make it a
better place those two things could work
together most of what we know about lady
true comes from PDP Dias stuff and
what her companies have done we know
that she's involved with cloning we've
seen her produce a baby for a couple to
trade for their farm we know that she
created nostalgia the drug that lets you
live in your past memories we know that
she's given everyone HD TVs in the area
for the inconvenience that her
construction caused we know that she's
working with will like I said he's got
mesmerism technology that can work as
mind control technology people have
guessed that she might be trying to
erase people's memories that she might
be trying to hit people with an empathy
bomb to make them care give people other
people's memories to make them more
empathetic and the reality is that we
just don't know we know that she has
cloned her own mother and that would
lead us to the next big question of who
is her father she said she wanted her
parents to be with her when she
celebrated her life's achievements
that's why she brought her mother back
in the form of a clone and that her
father would be there too there really
aren't that many choices it has to be
somebody that we know someone who's
connected to the story I would say that
I think it should be someone who's
connected to her in the current story
someone that we know and that's why I
think it's probably Adrian Veidt I can't
give you a good reason for that other
than the fact that they're connected
there's nothing in the original story
that made me think that he would want to
have children or perhaps he has children
so there's gonna have to be an
explanation to go along with that but I
have trust in the writers that they can
make that something interesting the
other candidates would be dr. Manhattan
just because he's there or Laurie
Blake's father who was the comedian a
lot of people liked the idea that it
might be the comedian I am NOT a fan of
the theory many people have said this
because he was in Vietnam that's a big
part of his story he actually killed a
pregnant woman in the story as well so
some people think that dr. Manhattan
might have somehow saved the baby and
that might be lady true but there's a
couple things that go against that for
me one they haven't talked about the
comedian much at all in the actual TV
show he's been dead for a long time he's
the one who died as the murder mystery
in the comic book and the other reason I
don't like it is because in the PD pedia
file they said that her mother had
a parenting book so I don't like the
idea that dr. Manhattan might have saved
the woman in the comic books life
however that doesn't mean that the
comedian couldn't be her father but I
just don't think it lines up with what
we've learned and they do discredit the
idea in the lady true factor fiction
story that's up on the website so I
would be surprised if they go that way
speaking of major invite the next
question is about him and that's number
four what's up with Ozymandias it's a
general question I know but we know
where he is or at least where he was in
2016 that's the last time we've seen him
at the English manor on Europa I think
all of us expect that he's going to come
back and be a part of the story in 2019
so will he get there in the finale or is
he already there those are two questions
and is he connected with Lady true is he
her father if he is is he part of the
plan do they have a plan together that
they hatched even before he got sent to
Europa was getting sent to Europa part
of his plan we think that lady choose
the one who told him that dr. Manhattan
was on Europa so that could be a
possibility also we saw how much it was
bothering him that he wasn't being
recognized for saving humanity so you
have to think that he's always been
scheming and trying to think of a way
that he can get the glory that he
deserves his legacy his child that could
play a part in that there may be a
reason why he went to Europa there may
be something he learned while he was
there we really don't know so I just
want the whole Ozymandias Adrian Veidt
storyline to have an ending and I'm
looking forward to see what it is
number five is where is Looking Glass
looking glass went missing after the
seventh cavalry came to his house he was
devastated after learning that his
entire life of prepping for the next
squid attack the next interdimensional
excursion was all based on a lie
agent Petey went to go look for him he
wasn't there he killed all the people as
far as we can tell from the seventh
cavalry who showed up he seems to take
him one of their masks so what is he
going to do in relation to the end of
the story
I'm guessing he slipped behind the lines
and he's pretending to be a Calvary foot
soldier would he be trying to stop
whatever they're trying to do what he'd
just be trying to save Angela and
phonce - turning her in before to save
her life what would he do if adrian
veidt's showed up he doesn't seem like
he would be very happy to see the guy
who faked the squid attack that ruined
his life and that goes into the next one
number six will the truth about what
actually happened in New York get out we
know people in the government know what
happened we know that all the costume
adventurers involved that were there
know what happened but the general
public doesn't know that it was all a
hoax the seventh Cavalry and people who
believe in Rorschach's Journal they take
it as truth it still sounds just as
crazy to people in this universe as a
lot of conspiracy theory sound to us I
tend to think that lady true is working
with Adrian Veidt so it wouldn't be in
her interest to get the truth out there
it certainly wouldn't be in Adrian's
interest because he doesn't want people
to know that he pulled off a hoax so I
do wonder if that's going to stay a
secret
or not I mention the Asian PD and the
next question is who is loot man well we
get confirmation that it is agent PD
everything seems to point to it
especially after the last PD files came
out after episode eight I don't think
that he calls himself loot man I think
he'd probably call himself the Fogg
dancer but it certainly points to him
being the guy my real question about
loot man at this point is will they
actually confirm it or will that be an
ongoing mystery because really agent P D
is a candidate to be a season two main
character if you think about it it all
depends on what happens with Senator
Kean and dr. Manhattan of course Jon
Osterman Cal Hatton whatever you want to
call him but I think agent PT might be a
good candidate for the ongoing
Adventures of what he gets into after
his time in Tulsa my next big question
will be what is Laurie going to say when
she sees dr. Manhattan we know that she
still has feelings based on the suitcase
that she carries around and her calls
from the prayer booth she's being held
prisoner inside the JCPenney as she
likes to refer to it The Hideout
of the seventh Cavalry and that tachyon
cannon should have teleported him right
there into the cage that was right in
front of her so I think their reunion
could be a lot of fun I don't know how
she's gonna react if she already had an
idea that it was
I don't know why she would except for
their history the next big question
would be about will will Reeves hooded
justice the first costume adventurer
what's he really doing we learned in
Episode eight that he probably came back
to Tulsa based on dr. Manhattan visiting
him we know that the children have been
teleported to the Dream Land Theater in
downtown Tulsa which is right around the
corner from where Angela's bakery is and
where we see lady true in this picture
outside of the prayer boot from the
promotional picture so he's in town but
he's not at the millenium clock
according to that we know he killed
Judd Crawford that set everything in
motion that got Laurie Blake there that
got everything going we guess that him
and lady Tru know what the seventh
Cavalry are up to and they're not really
trying to stop it not to this point so
what is will trying to accomplish and
we'll talk about him some more when we
get into dr. Manhattan and so the last
big question is what is dr. Manhattan up
to who will he or has he transferred his
powers to what are the actual chances
that Senator Joe King jr. becomes the
next dr. Manhattan there's so much going
on here Jon Osterman believes that the
seventh Cavalry is going to destroy him
he's been vague about the details about
that though he certainly brought off the
idea of passing off his powers in the
bar with Angela when they met and that
doesn't seem like something that we
should be overlooking plus he explains
how it works with an egg and there have
been eggs all over the place throughout
this season the title of this episode is
see how they fly which is a lyric from
the Beatles song I am The Walrus in
which they say I am the Eggman and
speaking of the Eggman in dr. Manhattan
passing off his powers what was up with
will whenever he grabbed the egg out of
the boiling water and what did that mean
some people think that that means that
he has dr. Manhattan's powers before any
of this stuff that's getting ready to
happen at the end of the season happens
I really don't know I really don't know
what was going on with that egg what I
do know is that if Yuri watch episode 8
dr. Manhattan is doing a lot of things
whenever he is first waking up he seems
disoriented but he's also clearly doing
stuff he wanted Angela to see him on the
pool that's going to be
important for later he knows he's gonna
be transported out and he is definitely
taking care of business the more I think
about it the more I think that he's
probably gonna pass off his powers to
Angela
I think she'll inherit them for the end
I could be wrong it could already be
will Reeves her grandfather it could be
more than one person lady true might be
trying to give his powers to everyone or
she might be trying to keep them all for
herself empower her millennium clock
there's just so many different ways that
this can go those are the biggest
questions I have that I expect to find
answers to I'm super curious to hear
what you guys are thinking about where
you think it's all headed what are the
answers to these questions and what are
the other questions you have there's
lots of little things that I hope that
they tie together why the lettuce is
involved what's the deal with the watch
batteries all sorts of what was up with
Panda and why was his mask so dirty
how's the American Hero story gonna play
out is that gonna play a part why did
they show us a scene of that pamphlet
being written before wills father got it
in World War one I do have a feeling
that Jon Osterman is gonna die in the
end I think he knows that's gonna happen
I don't know what that means for Cal it
would be kind of hilarious
if Joe King jr. is turned into Cal
rather than getting dr. manhattan's
powers and that whole transfer thing
there is so many different ways that it
can all go in less than three days we
will know the answers to all these
questions I'm gonna leave it there
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching all
my Watchmen videos thanks for watching
the show with me I'll talk to you soon